sri lanka has received 787 million
dollars from the international monetary
fund and 150 million dollars from the
bangladesh central bank this was all
part of an effort to boost the
struggling nation's foreign exchange
reserves which have been depleted as it
struggles to recover from the
coronavirus pandemic the kind of funding
that the imf has sent to the island is
called a special drawing rights it's a
special kind of international reserve
asset
and is very very rarely used
last in 2009
now sri lankan president gotabaya
rajapaska declared a state of emergency
over food shortages as banks run out of
foreign exchange to finance imports he
named a top army officer as commissioner
general of essential services to
coordinate the limited supply of paddy
rice sugar and other groceries long
queues have formed outside stores and
supermarkets many shelves are already
empty milk powder and cooking oil are
virtually impossible to get
people have also had to wait for hours
to fill their motorbikes rickshaws and
cars with gasoline the energy minister
has appealed to motorists to use fuel
sparingly warning that it could be
rationed by the end of the year unless
consumption was reduced the asian
country is suffering from the economic
fallout of the pandemic the economy in
sri lanka shrank 3.6 last year
and even though growth has returned the
money shortage means that the government
cannot even buy enough medicine
to supply hospitals
earlier i spoke to ganesh mortim an
economist at the university of colombo
i asked him what factors had sparked
this crisis
a foreign issue is one thing because sri
lanka imports
some food items like sugar and
other essential items
on top of that sri lanka entire depend
on imports for its gasoline need and
also gas so
the shortages are now
in
gas and petrol that's sometimes back uh
the shortages are there because of these
uh shortages in foreign currencies so
this country's foreign reserves have
been depleted to the alarming level so
the government could not maintain its
import flow into the country so there
was a
serious uh
import control regime has been
in place put in place
so
the local
production of rice and other commodities
vegetables and other commodities uh uh
basically we have seen uh there is no no
reason for the shortage as of now
um the especially the rice it has been
produced adequately
but
we can't see them in the in the in the
market i think in adequate quantities so
something went wrong
somewhere so the
emergency regulation
is intended to bring this rice into the
market i think
and
how have these food shortages been
impacting people in sri lanka so far
uh indeed the food shortage has
pushed these prices prices of essential
commodities uh for example i can give
you some figures on rice
it was earlier sold at
0.35
euro cents
to can make a comparison and now it is
0.5 euro cents so for a
ordinary family that's a huge increase
in the stable food price so it's it's
very difficult for ordinary family to
get ordinary rice not only rice all of
the commodities we have seen that the
prices are now climbing up you know
disproportionately so uh it's for our
ordinary family it's very difficult to
manage with the situation
ganesha morty m from the university of
colombo there thank you for talking to
us
in the middle of sri lanka's economic
crisis comes a new initiative by the
government to improve the country's
biggest export tea
but what was meant well might push the
entire industry in danger
the soil on this sunny plantation
produces one of the best teas in the
world
as do neighboring plantations all across
sri lanka
tea connoisseurs appreciate the
country's sale on tea for its color and
taste
tea is sri lanka's main export bringing
in more than one and a quarter billion
dollars a year and accounting for about
10 percent of the country's export
income but president kotabaya
rajapaksa's recent ban on chemical
fertilizers has growers worried their
plants depend on the nutrients they are
fed
it is the urea and the nitrogen content
that in that
forces the growth of the tea party of
the bud
and of the green leaf without it
you can
you can expect the decline in production
by as much as 50 percent
rajapaksa's idea was to make sale on tea
entirely organic and ready for a fast
growing market but tea growers worry
about their harvest
and about the economic consequences of a
failed policy which would go far beyond
the loss of income
to number one
make a big dent in the foreign exchange
earnings of the country number two
it is going to render a great part of
our population unemployed
three million people in sri lanka work
as tea pickers add to that workers on
cinnamon and pepper plantations that are
expected to face similar problems if the
fertilizer ban is not lifted and time is
of the essence
our chemical fertilizers reserves will
last about two months maximum after that
we need replenishments if we don't get
that in time there will be a very
drastic drop in crop of tea leaves
but right now president raja paksa
doesn't seem to be willing to change
course he's betting on improved
long-term food security for sri lankans
hopes the tea growers aren't sharing